Hey there Shankar here. One lesson that 2020 has taught us over and over again is that it's very hard to predict the future. We don't know what will happen tomorrow, much less what the world will look like in a month or a year from now. But one thing we can do is to use the past to try to understand the present. We've been thinking a lot in recent weeks about a conversation I had a while ago with historian Annette Gordon-Reed. Annette studies the life of Thomas Jefferson and the enslaved people who lived on his plantation. Thomas Jefferson, of course, is the founding father who wrote the phrase, all men are created equal in the Declaration of Independence. The gulf between his professed values and his behavior is rich psychological terrain. It also reveals
你好，我是尚卡尔。2020年反复教给我们的一课是：预测未来非常困难。我们不知道明天会发生什么，更不用说一个月或一年后的世界会是什么样子。但我们能做的一件事，就是利用过去来尝试理解现在。最近几周，我一直在思考我前段时间与历史学家安妮特·戈登-里德进行的一次谈话。安妮特研究托马斯·杰斐逊的生活，以及生活在他种植园里的被奴役者。当然，托马斯·杰斐逊是《独立宣言》中写下“人人生而平等”这句话的开国元勋。他所宣扬的价值观与他的行为之间的鸿沟，是一片丰富的心理领域。它也揭示了
something about the gap between our own professed values and our actions today. Here's the show. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. All nations are built on stories. The stories about ideals, the values around which people stake their identity. The values around which a people stake their identity. The individual fight on the beaches, the individual fight on the landing ground, might be the might.
我们今天所宣扬的价值观与我们的行为之间的差距。节目开始了。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。所有的国家都是建立在故事之上的。关于理想的故事，关于人们以此为身份认同的价值观。关于人们以此为身份认同的价值观。在海滩上的个人战斗，在登陆点的个人战斗，可能是力量所在。
That's what it means to be Australian. The only thing that Germany is saying is that we are not going to be Australian. Let's build on brains. God bless Africa. I thank you. Often these stories contain contradictions. Some so profound that most of us simply look the other way. The United States has its own set of founding myths and its own set of contradictions.
这就是成为澳大利亚人的意义。德国唯一在说的是，我们不会成为澳大利亚人。让我们在智慧的基础上建设。上帝保佑非洲。谢谢你们。这些故事往往包含矛盾。有些矛盾如此深刻，以至于我们大多数人只是选择视而不见。美国有自己的一套建国神话，也有自己的一套矛盾。
The United States has its own set of founding myths and its own set of contradictions. One of the most striking unfolded in 1776 at a house on the southwest corner of 7th and Market Streets in Philadelphia. That summer, 33-year-old Thomas Jefferson rented rooms at this house. While he was there, he wrote the document that would formalize America's split from Britain, the Declaration of Independence. It says, we hold these truths to be self-evident, that all men are created equal. That they are endowed by their creator with certain unalienable rights.
美国有自己的一套建国神话，也有自己的一套矛盾。其中最引人注目的一个发生在1776年，地点是费城第七街和市场街西南角的一所房子里。那个夏天，33岁的托马斯·杰斐逊在这所房子里租了房间。当他在那里时，他写下了将使美国与英国正式分裂的文件——《独立宣言》。它写道：我们认为这些真理是不言而喻的，即人人生而平等。他们被造物主赋予了某些不可剥夺的权利。
That among these are life, and the pursuit of happiness. And yet, even as he was writing these inspiring words, Jefferson was attended on by a slave. He was a 14-year-old boy named Robert Hemings. Jefferson, in fact, owned hundreds of slaves. He fathered six children with an enslaved woman. Today we take a deep dive into history as a window into psychology.
其中包括生命权和追求幸福的权利。然而，即使在写下这些鼓舞人心的文字时，杰斐逊身边也有一名奴隶在伺候他。那是一个名叫罗伯特·赫明斯的14岁男孩。事实上，杰斐逊拥有数百名奴隶。他与一名被奴役的女性育有六个孩子。今天，我们将深入探讨历史，将其作为洞察心理学的一扇窗户。
We look closely at the life and beliefs of a man who shaped the modern United States and ask how his complexities and contradictions have echoes in our own lives. How our minds justify our choices this week on Hidden Brain. Thomas Jefferson is remembered as a founding father of the United States, but historian Annette Gordon Reed looks at his life beyond the writing of the Declaration of Independence. She and her co-author Peter Onough explore Jefferson's inner life in their book, Most Blessed of the Patriarchs, Thomas Jefferson, and the Empire of the Imagination. And that, welcome to Hidden Brain. Glad to be here. Thank you for asking.
我们仔细审视了一位塑造了现代美国的人的生活和信仰，并询问他的复杂性和矛盾如何在我们的生活中产生回响。我们的思想如何为我们的选择辩护，本周在《隐藏的大脑》中。托马斯·杰斐逊被铭记为美国的开国元勋，但历史学家安妮特·戈登-里德审视了他撰写《独立宣言》之外的生活。她和合著者彼得·奥诺夫在他们的书《最受祝福的族长：托马斯·杰斐逊与想象力的帝国》中探讨了杰斐逊的内心生活。欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴来到这里。谢谢你的邀请。
The story of Jefferson and the story of slavery in the United States are deeply intertwined. I understand that Jefferson's earliest memory involved a slave. Yes, he told his grandchildren that his earliest memory was of being handed up on a pillow to an enslaved person. As his family was making a move from his boyhood home of Shadwell to Tuckahoe plantation. And so making this journey with his siblings and his parents Jefferson was carried by
杰斐逊的故事和美国奴隶制的故事是紧密交织在一起的。我了解到杰斐逊最早的记忆与一名奴隶有关。是的，他告诉他的孙辈，他最早的记忆是被人抱在枕头上，递给一个被奴役的人。当时他的家人正从他童年的家沙德威尔搬到塔卡霍种植园。因此，在与他的兄弟姐妹和父母一起踏上这段旅程时，杰斐逊是由一名
enslaved person, and so he says that that was his first memory. And of course slavery continued to play an important part in his life throughout his childhood. When he turned 21, he inherited 5,000 acres and a number of slaves. About a decade later following his marriage, he received another two plantations and even more slaves. What did he do with all this land and human property? Well, he basically lived the life of a planter. In slave people planted tobacco at first and then later wheat. They served in his household. They were the source of his wealth. He was a lawyer by trade, but
被奴役的人抱着，所以他说那是他的第一段记忆。当然，奴隶制在他整个童年时期继续在他的生活中扮演着重要角色。当他21岁时，他继承了5000英亩土地和一些奴隶。大约十年后，在他结婚后，他又获得了两个种植园和更多的奴隶。他用这些土地和人类财产做了什么？嗯，他基本上过着种植园主的生活。被奴役的人起初种植烟草，后来种植小麦。他们在他的家里服务。他们是他财富的来源。他以律师为业，但
being a plantation owner was the sort of basic understanding of himself, the basic part of his life. Even as he became a slave holder, Jefferson also thought of himself as being an educated and cultured man. He read voraciously, he loved music, he considered himself to be a man of science and reason. And much of his learning taught him that slavery was a terrible institution, but slavery was also, as we've discovered, essential to his way of life.
成为一名种植园主是他对自己基本理解的一部分，是他生活的基本部分。即使在成为奴隶主的同时，杰斐逊也认为自己是一个受过教育和有文化的人。他如饥似渴地阅读，热爱音乐，认为自己是一个崇尚科学和理性的人。他所学的大部分知识告诉他，奴隶制是一种可怕的制度，但正如我们所发现的，奴隶制也是他生活方式中必不可少的一部分。
What do Jefferson's early writings tell us about his views about this contradiction? Well, he thought of himself as I indicated a progressive person. And I have to remember that a lot of people who would be considered cultured and educated people were slave owners, but the difference between them and Jefferson is that they never came to the conclusion that slavery was wrong. The whole commerce between master and slave is a perpetual exercise of the most boisterous passions, the most unremitting despotism on the one part and degrading submissions on the other.
杰斐逊早期的著作告诉我们他关于这种矛盾的观点是什么？嗯，正如我所指出的，他认为自己是一个进步的人。我必须记住，许多被认为是受过文化和教育的人都是奴隶主，但他们与杰斐逊的区别在于，他们从未得出奴隶制是错误的结论。主人和奴隶之间的整个商业往来，是一场永无止境的、最狂暴的激情的演习，一方面是最无情的专制，另一方面是屈辱的顺从。
Our children see this and learn to imitate it. For man is an imitative animal. The interesting thing about him is that as a young man, he saw himself as a part of or an adherent to the notion of the Enlightenment. And being anti-slave trade, anti-slavery was one of the tenets that many people thought was a part of all of that. So I think he saw it as something that would gradually, and that's the thing that trips us up, gradually end, as people became more enlightened and learned more, that they would
我们的孩子看到这一点并学会模仿它。因为人是一种模仿动物。关于他有趣的一点是，作为一个年轻人，他认为自己是启蒙运动的一部分或追随者。而反对奴隶贸易、反对奴隶制是许多人认为属于这一切的原则之一。所以我认为他将其视为一种会逐渐结束的事情——而这正是让我们感到困惑的地方——随着人们变得更加开明和了解更多，他们会
realize that slavery was a backwards institution, an institution from ancient times. I think he thought it was just as we learned new scientific thoughts, just as we learn new ways to make machines that are better, that the machinery of society would change as well. And Jefferson was a great believer in progress and things being better in the future than they were in the present. Absolutely. And that's part of that's a strength and a weakness. Some people say the optimism was almost too great, but he definitely thought that mankind and society
意识到奴隶制是一种落后的制度，一种来自古代的制度。我想他认为，正如我们学习新的科学思想，正如我们学习制造更好的机器的新方法一样，社会的机制也会随之改变。杰斐逊非常相信进步，相信未来会比现在更好。绝对是这样。这是他的优势，也是他的弱点。有些人说这种乐观情绪太强烈了，但他确实认为人类和社会
would get better and better. In her book, Inette writes, Jefferson was a lifetime participant in an ancient system that made him the master of hundreds of people over whom he had near absolute power. He could buy and sell human beings. If hostility to tyranny was at the heart of his politics and plan for the United States of America, that sentiment had no real currency on his mountain.
会变得越来越好。在她的书中，安妮特写道，杰斐逊终身参与了一个古老的制度，这使他成为数百人的主人，他对这些人拥有近乎绝对的权力。他可以买卖人类。如果对暴政的敌意是他政治和美国计划的核心，那么这种情绪在他的山上并没有真正的流通。
At the same time, he well understood the basic problem with his way of life and wrote damning and insightful criticisms of the institution that made it possible. I asked an ad whether this made Jefferson a hypocrite. You could say that, but I think he was hypocritical in the way that many people are hypocritical and that all of us are hypocritical when we have an intellectual belief about something, but we don't have the will to act upon those beliefs. Jefferson did not know what to do about slavery.
与此同时，他非常了解他生活方式的基本问题，并对使之成为可能的制度写下了深刻而严厉的批评。我问安妮特，这是否使杰斐逊成为一个伪君子。你可以这么说，但我认为他的虚伪方式与许多人一样，当我们对某事有理性的信念，但却没有意志去根据这些信念采取行动时，我们所有人都是虚伪的。杰斐逊不知道该如何处理奴隶制。
Slavery was not just an economic system, it was a system of social control. What do you do with black Virginians when they are emancipated? How do they fit into society? I just don't think he could see what a sort of real plan, a realistic plan for what to do about it. And that's something that we grapple with in lots of areas, believing one thing, but not having the strength to do something about it,
奴隶制不仅仅是一种经济制度，它还是一种社会控制制度。当黑人弗吉尼亚人被解放时，你该拿他们怎么办？他们如何融入社会？我只是不认为他能看到一个真正的计划，一个关于如何处理这个问题的现实计划。这是我们在许多领域都在努力解决的问题，相信一件事，却没有力量去为此做点什么，
or to actually make that idea come to fruition if you have the shot. This ambivalence towards slavery became even more difficult to navigate after Jefferson went to Paris in 1784 on behalf of the new US government. When Jefferson went to Paris, he took a man named James Hemings, who was a teenager, 18, 19 years old at the time, and he took James with him to have James trained as a chef, a French chef.
或者如果你有机会，无法真正让那个想法实现。在杰斐逊于1784年代表美国新政府前往巴黎后，这种对奴隶制的矛盾心理变得更加难以驾驭。当杰斐逊去巴黎时，他带了一个名叫詹姆斯·赫明斯的年轻人，当时他十几岁，18、19岁，他带詹姆斯去接受培训，成为一名厨师，一名法国厨师。
So there was some tension here because France, of course, at the time was, you know, resounding with the cries of liberty and equality and Jefferson in some ways embraced French revolutionary fervor. But how did he manage that embrace of the revolution with the slaves he had in his own household? Well, the way he handled enslaved people in our James Hemings, when he was in France, had much more to do with French law, which at the time was on the side of the enslaved person. I mean, people who petitioned for freedom in France, people who had been brought from the colonies and so forth, or other enslaved people who were brought there from other places, who petitioned for freedom had those petitions granted routinely.
所以这里有一些紧张关系，因为当时的法国当然充斥着自由和平等的呼声，而杰斐逊在某些方面拥抱了法国革命的热情。但他如何处理这种对革命的拥抱与他自己家里的奴隶之间的关系呢？嗯，他在法国时处理被奴役者詹姆斯·赫明斯的方式，与当时的法国法律有很大关系，当时的法律站在被奴役者一边。我的意思是，在法国申请自由的人，从殖民地被带到那里的人，或者从其他地方被带到那里的其他被奴役者，他们申请自由的请求通常都会得到批准。
So when he's there with James Hemings, he knows that it's possible that James might, at some point, petition for his freedom. So he handles this, I think, although he doesn't say this, but this is the time when he begins to pay James Heming's regular wages. James becomes the chef de cuisine at the Hotel de la Giacca Jefferson's residence. Before he had been giving James spending money, or gratuities, but once James takes over the role as the chef de cuisine, he begins to pay him. So I think he handles it by treating James as if he were a regular servant and instead of an enslaved person. Jefferson's wife had died by the time he got to France. At one point, a young slave was brought over from the United States.
所以当他和詹姆斯·赫明斯在一起时，他知道詹姆斯在某个时候可能会申请自由。所以我认为他处理这个问题的方式是——尽管他没有明说，但这是他开始支付詹姆斯·赫明斯固定工资的时候。詹姆斯成为了杰斐逊住所拉贾克酒店的行政主厨。在此之前，他一直给詹姆斯零花钱或小费，但一旦詹姆斯接手行政主厨的角色，他就开始支付工资。所以我认为他通过把詹姆斯当作普通仆人而不是被奴役者来处理这个问题。杰斐逊到达法国时，他的妻子已经去世了。有一次，一个年轻的奴隶从美国被带了过来。
She's actually the sister of Robert Hemings, who was by his side as he drafted the Declaration of Independence. Who was she and what did she become to Jefferson? Well, Sally Hemings, Sarah, nicknamed Sally, was sister to Robert and James. She had been something of a companion to Jefferson's daughter. So she went along and she was 14. And Sally Hemings crossed the ocean. And while is there we don't know when she became Jefferson's and their son says cocky-bind is the term that he uses and she became pregnant
她实际上是罗伯特·赫明斯的妹妹，罗伯特在杰斐逊起草《独立宣言》时就在他身边。她是谁，她对杰斐逊来说成了什么人？嗯，萨莉·赫明斯，莎拉，昵称萨莉，是罗伯特和詹姆斯的妹妹。她曾是杰斐逊女儿的伴侣。所以她跟着去了，当时她14岁。萨莉·赫明斯跨越了大洋。当她在那里时，我们不知道她什么时候成了杰斐逊的——他们的儿子说“同居”是他使用的词——她怀孕了
by Jefferson and she wanted to stay in France. By the time Jefferson thinks that he wants to come home, she wanted to stay. And actually, all of the young people in the hotel in Long-Yahk wanted to stay in France. Nobody wanted to go home. But Jefferson promised her that if she came back with him, she would have a good life at Monticello, and their children would be freed when they were 21 years old. So she agreed to that, she was 16 years old at the time, and she came back to Virginia with Jefferson. So for us at least with the advantage of history,
杰斐逊的孩子，她想留在法国。当杰斐逊认为他想回家时，她想留下来。事实上，酒店里的所有年轻人都想留在法国。没有人想回家。但杰斐逊向她承诺，如果她和他一起回去，她在蒙蒂塞洛会过上好日子，他们的孩子在21岁时会被释放。所以她同意了，当时她16岁，她和杰斐逊一起回到了弗吉尼亚。所以至少对我们来说，利用历史的优势，
this seems almost incomprehensible as a decision. Why would you give up essentially freedom in France to come back and be a slave in Virginia? I thought about that quite a bit. When I wrote my first book, that was sort of a point of mystery for me about Sally Hemings. But when I started writing the Hemings as a Monticello and working on that,
这作为一个决定似乎几乎不可理解。为什么你要放弃在法国的自由，回到弗吉尼亚做奴隶？我对此思考了很多。当我写我的第一本书时，那对我来说是关于萨莉·赫明斯的一个谜。但当我开始写蒙蒂塞洛的赫明斯一家并着手研究时，
and I realized how important family was or I began to think about how important family would have been to someone like that. A 16-year-old female raised to believe that she had some special connection to family in a way, to think about family, think about your mother is back in Virginia, her sisters and brothers were there. So that would be an impetus. I mean that was sort of a dilemma that many enslaved people faced Do you run away and have freedom by yourself or do you Stay and stick it out with your family the other thing to consider is that Jefferson treated Sally Hemings and her sisters and brothers very differently than he did the other slaves on the mountain
我意识到家庭是多么重要，或者我开始思考家庭对那样的人来说会有多重要。一个16岁的女孩，从小被教育认为她与家庭有某种特殊的联系，想到家庭，想到你的母亲在弗吉尼亚，她的姐妹和兄弟都在那里。这会是一种动力。我的意思是，这是许多被奴役者面临的困境：你是独自逃跑获得自由，还是留下来与家人共度难关？另一件要考虑的事情是，杰斐逊对待萨莉·赫明斯和她的姐妹兄弟的方式与他对待山上的其他奴隶非常不同。
She had seen him let her brothers sort of wander and go off and hire their own time work for themselves make keep their own money The enslaved women on the plantation all but the Hemings has had to go to the fields at harvest time. The Hemings' sisters did not do that. They were constructed in a different way. And so I might have a different view of Jefferson. I have a particular view of Jefferson from this particular time and seeing him as, for lack of a better term, an enemy of these people, but it's not clear to me that she would have seen it in exactly
她曾见过他让她的兄弟们四处走动，去为自己工作，保留自己的钱。种植园里所有的被奴役女性，除了赫明斯一家，都必须在收获季节去田里干活。赫明斯姐妹没有这样做。她们的处境不同。所以我可能对杰斐逊有不同的看法。我从这个特定时期对杰斐逊有特定的看法，把他看作是——用一个更好的词来说——这些人的敌人，但我不清楚她是否会完全以同样的方式看待他。
the same way that I did. And that's one of the things you have to do when you're writing history is whatever you would want people to do, they may not think about things in the same way. So family and her history with Jefferson, not just the two of them, but his relations with her mother and her brothers and all of these people, likely colored the way she considered making this decision. And of course, she was, she was still a child. Yes, well, she was, by our light, she was a child.
这就是你在写历史时必须做的事情之一，无论你希望人们做什么，他们可能不会以同样的方式思考问题。所以家庭和她与杰斐逊的历史，不仅仅是他们两个，还有他与她母亲和兄弟以及所有这些人的关系，很可能影响了她考虑做出这个决定的方式。当然，她当时还是个孩子。是的，好吧，按照我们的标准，她是个孩子。
She was 16, the age of consent in Virginia at the time was 10, and they raised it to 12 in the 1820s, and it was that way through the 19th century and most of the state to the union. So a 16 year old person to us is like a baby, but a 16 year old person at that time would not have been thought of as a child. When you talk about this familial ties that basically potentially brought Sally back to Virginia, it's also worth pointing out that Sally Hemings and Thomas Jefferson in some ways were already
她16岁，当时弗吉尼亚州的同意年龄是10岁，在19世纪20年代提高到了12岁，整个19世纪大部分时间在联邦各州都是这样。所以对我们来说，16岁的人就像个婴儿，但在那个时代，16岁的人不会被认为是孩子。当你谈论这种基本上可能把萨莉带回弗吉尼亚的家庭纽带时，也值得指出的是，萨莉·赫明斯和托马斯·杰斐逊在某种程度上已经
related even before they got together in Paris. Can you talk a little bit about that? Oh yes. Well, the Hemings children, Robert and James and Sally Hemings and three other siblings were the children of a woman named Elizabeth Hemings and a man named John Wales. And John Wales, from whom Jefferson inherited the 135 slaves and including the Hemings family, was the father of these six children. So Jefferson's wife and Sally Hemings were half sisters. So this connection between the Hemings and Jefferson's really gets going through Jefferson's
有亲戚关系了，甚至在他们在巴黎相聚之前。你能谈谈这个吗？哦，是的。嗯，赫明斯家的孩子，罗伯特、詹姆斯和萨莉·赫明斯以及其他三个兄弟姐妹，是一个名叫伊丽莎白·赫明斯的女人和一个名叫约翰·威尔斯的男人的孩子。约翰·威尔斯是杰斐逊继承那135名奴隶（包括赫明斯一家）的人，他是这六个孩子的父亲。所以杰斐逊的妻子和萨莉·赫明斯是同父异母的姐妹。所以赫明斯一家和杰斐逊一家的这种联系确实是通过杰斐逊的
wife. It's interestingly enough when John Wales dies and Jefferson and his wife inherit the enslaved people, including the Hemings'. They bring the Hemings' two Monticello and they are installed as sort of the favored servants of Jefferson and his wife, which is interesting because in many situations where a white plantation mistress had a father or a son or a husband who had children with an enslaved woman, they pressured them to sell the children or to move them to some other distant place.
妻子建立起来的。有趣的是，当约翰·威尔斯去世，杰斐逊和他的妻子继承了包括赫明斯一家在内的被奴役者时，他们把赫明斯一家带到了蒙蒂塞洛，并将他们安置为杰斐逊和他妻子的宠仆，这很有趣，因为在许多情况下，白人种植园的女主人如果有一个与被奴役女性生了孩子的父亲、儿子或丈夫，她们会施压让他们卖掉这些孩子或把他们搬到其他遥远的地方。
But I find it fascinating that Martha didn't take that route. She actually brought these people, and I'm sure she's doing this through her husband, to Monticello, and she wanted them in her life, which we don't know very much about Martha Jefferson. and she wanted them in her life, which we don't know very much about Martha Jefferson, but this is sort of an interesting point about her personality, I think, that rather than hide away the children of her father, she actually brings them into her household. So once they're back in Monte Chaleau, the estate in Virginia, which was Jefferson's home,
但我发现玛莎没有走那条路，这很迷人。她实际上把这些人——我相信她是透过她的丈夫这样做的——带到了蒙蒂塞洛，她希望他们出现在她的生活中，我们对玛莎·杰斐逊了解不多，但这是她性格中一个有趣的方面，我认为，与其隐藏她父亲的孩子，她实际上把他们带进了她的家庭。所以一旦他们回到弗吉尼亚州的蒙蒂塞洛庄园，也就是杰斐逊的家，
he went on to father six children with Sally Hemings, but at the same time he also had a white family that was also a part of his life. How did he navigate having these two separate families under the same roof? Well, because he was the patriarch of Monticello, and in those days it was much more than father knows best, what he said would go because he was the head of the household. I think it's also important to remember that Jefferson had two surviving daughters with his wife, you know, who died in 1782. So I think he handled it by being the boss boss and it was the kind of thing that people would not question.
他继续与萨莉·赫明斯育有六个孩子，但与此同时，他也有一个白人家庭，也是他生活的一部分。他是如何在同一个屋檐下处理这两个独立的家庭的？嗯，因为他是蒙蒂塞洛的族长，在那个时代，这不仅仅是“父亲最懂”，因为他是户主，他所说的话算数。我认为记住杰斐逊与他的妻子（1782年去世）有两个幸存的女儿也很重要。所以我认为他处理这个问题的方式是成为老板中的老板，这是人们不会质疑的事情。
So he had basically the freedom to impose a kind of order on this place that everybody would along with. Plus, you have to remember, I think we have to remember that he wasn't married. And the idea that a man would have a mistress or a companion or that he would have a setup like this was normal in Virginia. It was not considered crazy. One of Jefferson's friends said that it was a common practice for widowed or bachelor slave owners
所以他基本上有自由在这个地方强加一种秩序，每个人都会顺从。另外，你必须记住，我认为我们必须记住他没有结婚。男人会有情妇或伴侣，或者他会有这样的安排，这在弗吉尼亚是很正常的。这并不被认为是疯狂的。杰斐逊的一位朋友说，鳏夫或单身奴隶主有一种普遍的做法，
to take an enslaved woman as, and he he uses the phrase a substitute for a wife. Obviously she couldn't be a wife because they couldn't marry. Black people and white people could not get married. Well, until 1967 in Virginia. So that was out of the question. But this was something that happened in slavery. It's hard for us to wrap our minds around just as it might be hard for us to wrap our minds around about slavery in general.
即把一名被奴役的女性作为——他使用了“妻子的替代品”这个短语。显然她不能成为妻子，因为他们不能结婚。黑人和白人不能结婚。嗯，直到1967年在弗吉尼亚州。所以这根本不可能。但这确实是奴隶制中发生的事情。我们很难理解这一点，就像我们可能很难理解一般的奴隶制一样。
But mixed children, these kinds of connections from rape to sort of long-term liaisons, however you want to call them, were a part of slave societies. And they have been in every slave society that has ever existed. It's interesting, isn't it? Because I think when most of us at least lay people think about the institution of slavery you think about it in economic terms or political terms you don't really think about it in terms of these family relationships which may have been every bit as important in keeping the system intact as the economic and political advantages that slavery conferred on some people.
但是混血儿，从强奸到某种长期关系，无论你怎么称呼它们，都是奴隶社会的一部分。它们存在于曾经存在过的每一个奴隶社会中。这很有趣，不是吗？因为我认为当我们大多数人——至少是外行——想到奴隶制这种制度时，你会从经济或政治角度去想，你并没有真正从这些家庭关系的角度去想，而这些关系在维持制度完整方面可能与奴隶制赋予某些人的经济和政治优势一样重要。
Yes, but it also shows in some ways the deep horror of the institution, because you think of family relations as biological connections, we could say, as something that would foster a sense of, well, a sense of connection, and there is a sense of connection among some people, at least it was for the Hemmings and for Jefferson, but it warps everything. Because how can you have a true relationship? How can you have the kind of connection that we typically associate with family under these circumstances. But they people did. As I said, most people, this was they didn't care about the family connection at all. They sold children, they, you know, gave them away. But this was a very strange attempt to create something or to maintain something that is just very difficult for us to understand. When we come back, did Jefferson see the contradictions in his own life?
是的，但这在某种程度上也显示了这种制度的深刻恐怖，因为你把家庭关系视为生物联系，我们可以说，视为某种会培养一种——嗯，一种联系感的东西，在某些人之间确实有一种联系感，至少对赫明斯一家和杰斐逊来说是这样，但它扭曲了一切。因为在这种情况下，你怎么能有真正的关系？你怎么能有我们通常与家庭联系在一起的那种联系？但人们确实有了。正如我所说，大多数人，这——他们根本不在乎家庭联系。他们卖掉孩子，他们，你知道，把他们送人。但这是一种非常奇怪的尝试，试图创造或维持某种对我们来说非常难以理解的东西。当我们回来时，杰斐逊是否看到了他自己生活中的矛盾？
Stay with us. And at Thomas Jefferson saw himself as one of the fathers of the nation, but also as the patriarch of his own patch of paradise, this estate of Monticello in Virginia. How did Jefferson's sense of his obligations to his slaves shaped the way he felt about them? This notion of being a patriarch, which is kind of problematic for us these days, for Jefferson, it was not simply about the power he exercised over people. It would be about his sense of responsibility. And that, of course, grates with us because he's talking about responsibility over grown
请留步。托马斯·杰斐逊认为自己是国家的国父之一，但也是他自己那片天堂——弗吉尼亚州蒙蒂塞洛庄园——的族长。杰斐逊对奴隶的义务感是如何塑造他对他们的感情的？这种族长的概念，在今天对我们来说有点问题，但对杰斐逊来说，这不仅仅是他对人们行使的权力。这关乎他的责任感。当然，这让我们感到刺耳，因为他谈论的是对成年
men and women. You know, and you think, hey, they could be responsible for themselves, but his experiences in France with the Hemmings' with James and Sally Hemmings, they were the face of slavery for him. And he saw himself acting as a slaveholder through his relationships ships with them and he is treating them differently. He sees himself buying clothes for James, paying James a full salary in France and continuing to do so when they come back to the United States, treating them in a different sort of way. He sees himself as a good, quote unquote, good and benevolent master. Now, we bought at that and rightfully so, but he saw himself as doing slavery in the right way, if it had to be done. And once you start to acquiesce or think of yourself as a good slave owner, I think the urgency
男女的责任。你知道，你会想，嘿，他们可以对自己负责，但他在法国与赫明斯一家的经历——与詹姆斯和萨莉·赫明斯的经历——他们对他来说是奴隶制的面孔。他通过与他们的关系来看待自己作为奴隶主的行为，他对待他们的方式不同。他看到自己为詹姆斯买衣服，在法国支付詹姆斯全额工资，并在他们回到美国后继续这样做，以一种不同的方式对待他们。他认为自己是一个“好的”，引用引号，“好的”和仁慈的主人。现在，我们对此表示反对，这是理所当然的，但他认为自己是在以正确的方式实行奴隶制，如果必须实行的话。一旦你开始默许或认为自己是一个好的奴隶主，我认为
about ending slavery dissipates. I have my house to build my fields to form and to watch for the happiness of those who labor for mine. Can you talk a moment about how Jefferson related to the slaves that he owned in terms of the violence that he and his overseer's perpetrator on them? Well, there's no record of Jefferson ever beating anybody, but overseers at Monticello and his other plantations did use the whip. The whip was ubiquitous part of control on plantations, but Jefferson developed the idea that using incentives would be a better way to get people to do things than to whip them.
结束奴隶制的紧迫感就会消失。我有我的房子要建，我的田地要耕种，还要照顾那些为我劳动的人的幸福。你能谈谈杰斐逊在暴力方面是如何对待他拥有的奴隶的吗？他和他手下的监工对他们施加了暴力。嗯，没有记录显示杰斐逊曾经打过任何人，但蒙蒂塞洛和他其他种植园的监工确实使用了鞭子。鞭子是种植园控制中无处不在的一部分，但杰斐逊发展出一种想法，即使用激励措施比鞭打更能让人们做事。
It would destroy their value in my estimation to degrade them in their own eyes by the whip. This, therefore, must not be resorted to, but in extremities. And while he was thinking about this, he read a number of books about changes in prison. It's the way that people dealt with prisoners and penitentiaries, and the idea was incentives worked better than after the fact punishments. So in the 1790s, when he sets up a nail factory run by boys, typically, and older teenagers,
在我看来，用鞭子在他们自己眼中贬低他们会破坏他们的价值。因此，除非在极端情况下，否则不得诉诸此举。当他在思考这个问题时，他读了一些关于监狱改革的书。这是人们处理囚犯和监狱的方式，想法是激励措施比事后惩罚更有效。所以在18世纪90年代，当他建立了一个通常由男孩和较大的青少年经营的钉子工厂时，
he institutes a regime of incentives that they would get extra rations for food, they would get extra clothes, sometimes they would get money, they were paid gratuities. So this notion of incentives versus punishment or whipping was something that became a part of his way of making himself a quote unquote better slaveholder and that's the thing he tried to foster which made him more comfortable in his role as a master. In many ways I think it's hard to read your book without at least reading into it the
他建立了一套激励制度，他们会得到额外的食物配给，他们会得到额外的衣服，有时他们会得到钱，他们被支付小费。所以这种激励与惩罚或鞭打的概念，是他使自己成为一个“更好的”奴隶主的方式的一部分，这是他试图培养的东西，这使他在作为主人的角色中感到更自在。在许多方面，我认为如果不至少读出
possibility that Jefferson had at least in his own mind something approaching an intimate relationship with Sally Hemings that it was not just Master and Slave. Of course a lot of people have criticized you for this. She was a slave, she could not have given consent. How have you come to understand the relationship between Jefferson and Sally Hemings? You know, I go back and forth on this. I don't believe that every relationship between a enslaved woman and a master was exactly the same. I think there were different types of connections. And Jefferson, to me, shows signs of having been attached to Sally Hemings. I have no problem saying that because there are no stories about him with any other woman when he comes back from France, you know,
杰斐逊至少在他自己的脑海中与萨莉·赫明斯有某种接近亲密关系的可能性，就很难读懂你的书，这不仅仅是主人和奴隶。当然，很多人因此批评你。她是一个奴隶，她不可能给予同意。你是如何理解杰斐逊和萨莉·赫明斯之间的关系的？你知道，我对此反复思考。我不相信被奴役女性和主人之间的每一段关系都完全一样。我认为有不同类型的联系。对我来说，杰斐逊表现出与萨莉·赫明斯有感情的迹象。我毫不介意这么说，因为当他从法国回来后，没有关于他与其他任何女人的故事，你知道，
ever, but her. We don't know about her because once she gets back here, she is totally under his power. But if you look at the kinds of male, female relationships, they would have known at that time, a wife, a white wife would have been under the control of her husband too. She could not refuse consent to sex any more than a slave woman could. He could not sell his wife, but that would be about the only thing that he couldn't do. So we look at this and there's this sharp difference between male-female relationships. We see the difference between obviously a white woman has more power than an enslaved woman. But those people, Sally Hemings, would not have thought that as a woman she
除了她。我们不知道她的情况，因为一旦她回到这里，她就完全在他的权力之下。但如果你看看那个时代他们所知道的那种男女关系，白人妻子也会受到丈夫的控制。她拒绝性行为的同意并不比奴隶女性多。他不能卖掉他的妻子，但这几乎是他唯一不能做的事情。所以我们看看这个，男女关系之间存在这种尖锐的区别。我们看到白人女性显然比被奴役女性拥有更多权力的区别。但那些人，萨莉·赫明斯，不会认为作为一个女人她
would have freedom to do whatever she wanted. So it's complicated. We may not know how Sally Hemings felt, but we do know what Jefferson's critics had to say at the time. And that says Jefferson was rebuked by people who told him he had no business falling in love with a woman who wasn't white. The newspaper reports in you know when Jefferson is president were saying we're castigating him for saying you know why have you not found I'm kind of paraphrasing
会有自由去做她想做的任何事。所以这很复杂。我们可能不知道萨莉·赫明斯的感觉，但我们确实知道杰斐逊的批评者在当时是怎么说的。这说杰斐逊受到了人们的谴责，他们告诉他，他没有理由爱上一个不是白人的女人。报纸报道说，你知道，当杰斐逊担任总统时，他们正在抨击他，说，你知道，为什么你没有找到——我有点在转述
here but why have you not found a worthy woman of your own color? So people with people's objective to was not that he had a child with her, but it's that it seemed to be a continuing thing, and that put it too much like marriage, and that put it too much like the kinds of connections that white men had with white women. And so back at his time, that was the real objection. I understand that at the end of his life, Jefferson, in effect, freed Sally Hemings, but didn't do it in a way that just simply said, you know, you are now free. He did it in a more complicated fashion. Can you talk about what he did? Well, Sally Hemings was never formally freed. She left Monticello with her sons who were formally freed, the two youngest ones. The two eldest children went to live as white people and
这里——但为什么你没有找到一个和你自己肤色相当的值得尊敬的女人？所以人们反对的不是他与她生了孩子，而是这似乎是一件持续的事情，这让它看起来太像婚姻了，这让它看起来太像白人男性与白人女性之间的那种联系。所以回到他的时代，那是真正的反对意见。我了解到在他生命的尽头，杰斐逊实际上释放了萨莉·赫明斯，但并没有以一种仅仅说“你现在自由了”的方式去做。他以一种更复杂的方式做了这件事。你能谈谈他做了什么吗？嗯，萨莉·赫明斯从未被正式释放。她带着她的儿子们离开了蒙蒂塞洛，他们被正式释放了，是两个最小的儿子。两个最大的孩子去过白人的生活，
did not want freedom papers because that would indicate that they were enslaved in meaning that they were part black. So she is not formally freed. She's given her time and that's the phrase that they used. And. So she is not formally freed. She's given her time and that's the phrase that they used. And a possible reason for this, possible reasons, is that in order to free her, he would have had to put her name in his will and request that the legislature allow her to remain in Virginia. An 1806 law said that if you were freed, you had to leave the state within a year, unless you had permission from the government to stay. So, he probably would not have wanted to do that.
并且不想要自由文件，因为那会表明他们是被奴役的，意味着他们是部分黑人。所以她没有被正式释放。她被给予了她的时间，这就是他们使用的短语。而且。所以她没有被正式释放。她被给予了她的时间，这就是他们使用的短语。一个可能的原因，可能的原因是，为了释放她，他必须把她的名字写在他的遗嘱中，并请求立法机关允许她留在弗吉尼亚州。1806年的一项法律规定，如果你被释放，你必须在一年内离开该州，除非你得到政府的许可才能留下。所以，他可能不想那样做。
Second, she was over 45, and you could not free an enslaved person below 21 or over 45, unless you explained how you were going to provide for their care for the rest of their lives. And so he would have had to, in addition to putting her name in the will to ask for permission, he would have had to say, and here's the money that I'm going to give to support Sally Hemmings. And that would have been an admission, and he was not going to do that. So the community takes this notion that she is free and treat her as a free person, which I think talks a little bit about law and how law exists on the books and how you're supposed to formally do things, but if the community decides that you're a free person, she was treated as a free person.
其次，她已经超过45岁了，你不能释放21岁以下或45岁以上的被奴役者，除非你解释你将如何为他们的余生提供照顾。所以他不仅要在遗嘱中写下她的名字来请求许可，他还必须说，“这是我将要给出的支持萨莉·赫明斯的钱。”那将是一种承认，而他不会那样做。所以社区接受了她是自由的这个概念，并把她当作自由人对待，我认为这稍微谈到了法律以及法律如何在书面上存在，以及你应该如何正式地做事，但如果社区决定你是一个自由人，她就被当作自由人对待。
When we come back, the enduring legacy of Thomas Jefferson's contradictions and what his story tells us about the contradictions in our own lives. In 1824, Thomas Jefferson welcomed an old friend to his home at Monte Chalau. The friend was escorted by a crowd, a procession of cavalrymen and ordinary citizens. His approach was announced by a bugle. The name of Jefferson's friend was Marie Joseph Paul E. Vroge Gilbert du Montier. His street remembers him as the Marquis de Lafayette. My dear Marquis, Monsieur le président, I am very glad to see you my friend. Lafayette was a French aristocrat who was inspired by the American Revolution.
当我们回来时，托马斯·杰斐逊矛盾的持久遗产，以及他的故事告诉我们关于我们自己生活中矛盾的事情。1824年，托马斯·杰斐逊欢迎一位老朋友来到他在蒙蒂塞洛的家。这位朋友由一群人护送，这是一支由骑兵和普通公民组成的队伍。他的到来由号角宣布。杰斐逊朋友的名字是玛丽·约瑟夫·保罗·伊夫罗格·吉尔伯特·杜·蒙蒂埃。历史记得他是拉法耶特侯爵。我亲爱的侯爵，总统先生，我很高兴见到你，我的朋友。拉法耶特是一位受到美国革命启发的法国贵族。
He fought with the Americans and convinced France to provide crucial support to the American cause. Decades after the Revolution, Lafayette returned to the United States in 1824 for a now famous tour of the nation, including a visit to Thomas Jefferson's home in Virginia. 35 years of separation is too long indeed. I trust that your journey has not proved too tiring. Not at all. To the contrary. The two men had a lot to talk about on their visit.
他与美国人并肩作战，并说服法国为美国事业提供关键支持。革命几十年后，拉法耶特于1824年回到美国，进行了现在著名的全国巡回访问，包括访问托马斯·杰斐逊在弗吉尼亚州的家。35年的分离确实太长了。我相信你的旅程并没有证明太累人。一点也不。恰恰相反。这两位男士在访问期间有很多话要谈。
And Edgorton Reed says we know about the details of their conversation because of an enslaved man named Israel Gillette Jefferson, who was their carriage driver. He overhears this conversation. The conversation turned upon the condition of the colored people, the slaves. Lafayette always encouraged Jefferson, sort of needled Jefferson about this issue of slavery and emancipation. I feel I must express my continued concerns about the issue of Negro slavery.
安妮特·戈登-里德说，我们知道他们谈话的细节，因为一个名叫以色列·吉列·杰斐逊的被奴役者，他是他们的马车夫。他无意中听到了这段谈话。谈话转向了有色人种，即奴隶的状况。拉法耶特总是鼓励杰斐逊，有点像在奴隶制和解放问题上刺探杰斐逊。我觉得我必须表达我对黑人奴隶制问题的持续关注。
Lafayette remarked that no man could rightfully hold ownership in his brother-man, that instead of all being free, a portion were held in bondage, would seem to grieve his noble heart. I feel I must continue to press upon you how much I desire to see this plague cured before my death. Mr. Jefferson replied that he thought the time would come when the slaves would be free. In my dear Lafayette, you know where I stand on this issue. But he did not indicate when, or in what manner, they would get their freedom.
拉法耶特评论说，没有人能正当地拥有他的兄弟，即不是所有人都是自由的，一部分人被束缚，这似乎让他的高尚心灵感到悲伤。我觉得我必须继续向你强调，我多么渴望在死前看到这种瘟疫被治愈。杰斐逊先生回答说，他认为奴隶们终将获得自由的那一天会到来。我亲爱的拉法耶特，你知道我在这个问题上的立场。但他没有说明他们何时或以何种方式获得自由。
I am not apt to despair, yet I see not how our generation is to disengage itself from this deplorable entanglement. He seemed to think that the time had not then arrived. There's something deeply ironic about this, isn't it? I mean, you have these two people who are speaking about high ideals and about the importance of equality, and they're being driven around by somebody who's a slave, and you look at this and you say, how can you not see what is happening? Well, you do. We do.
我不容易绝望，但我看不出我们这一代人如何能从这种可悲的纠缠中解脱出来。他似乎认为那时还未到时机。这其中有些深刻的讽刺，不是吗？我的意思是，你有这两个谈论崇高理想和关于平等重要性的人，而他们正被一个奴隶开车到处走，你看着这个，你说，你怎么能看不出正在发生什么？嗯，你看到了。我们看到了。
Definitely do that. And I imagine, and this is not to minimize, as I would never do, the depredations of the institution of slavery, but I imagine a hundred years from now, people are going to look back at certain things that we do and say, why didn't people understand? You know, why didn't people do something? And there are a lot of times, human beings don't act according to what they know is the right thing to do. a lot of things, a lot of times human beings don't act according to what they know is the right thing to do. Monticello was Jefferson's place. This was his way of life. It's what he knew. And he
绝对看到了。我想——这并不是要最小化，我永远不会这样做——奴隶制制度的掠夺，但我认为一百年后，人们会回顾我们所做的一些事情，并说，为什么人们不明白？你知道，为什么人们不做点什么？有很多时候，人类并没有按照他们知道是正确的事情去做。很多事情，很多时候人类并没有按照他们知道是正确的事情去做。蒙蒂塞洛是杰斐逊的地方。这是他的生活方式。这是他所知道的。而他
felt that he helped to found a country. He helped the United States come into existence, breaking with Great Britain, setting up a government. That was a pretty big deal, and that the next generation of people had something to do as well, and that was to make the progress on the issue of slavery that he thought could be made. Now, we're not satisfied with that, because we say you had the talent to do this thing. Why didn't you use the talent to do the other thing? But that's not what he thought he was here to do.
觉得他帮助建立了一个国家。他帮助美国诞生，与英国决裂，建立了一个政府。那是一件大事，下一代人也有事情要做，那就是在奴隶制问题上取得他认为可以取得的进展。现在，我们对此并不满意，因为我们说你有天赋去做这件事。为什么你不利用天赋去做另一件事？但那不是他认为他在这里要做的事情。
The American Revolution was the most important thing in his life. And the tragedy is he couldn't see that after the unionist form, that the thing that would split it apart would be the institution of slavery. So, you know, it's a tragic story in a lot of ways, but I think it's not surprising, given human nature. We don't always do what we think or we know is the right thing to do. You know, it's so fascinating when you read Jefferson's story. I mean, it's an extraordinary story. I mean, he helped to overthrow monarchy. He helped to change, you know, archaic property rules. He changed the way we thought about the role of religion in politics. But when it came to slavery, you know, he didn't make as much progress as he could. And what's frustrating
美国革命是他一生中最重要的事情。悲剧在于，他没能预见到在联邦体制形成后，导致国家分裂的根源竟会是奴隶制。所以，从很多方面来看，这是一个悲剧性的故事，但我认为这并不令人惊讶，因为这就是人性。我们并不总是做我们认为正确或知道正确的事情。当你阅读杰斐逊的故事时，你会觉得非常迷人。我的意思是，这是一个非凡的故事。他帮助推翻了君主制。他帮助改变了陈旧的财产规则。他改变了我们对宗教在政治中作用的看法。但当谈到奴隶制时，他并没有取得他本可以取得的进展。令人沮丧的是，
is not just that he had the power, but he also had the insight that slavery as an institution was not a good institution. And I can't help but wonder, in all of those other cases, Jefferson really didn't stand anything to lose. I mean, he didn't stand to lose from overthrowing monarchy. He stood to gain from it. Oh, if they had lost, he would have lost his life. I mean, that was treason against the king to sign
不仅仅是他拥有权力，而且他也有洞察力，知道奴隶制作为一种制度并不是一种好的制度。我不禁想问，在所有其他情况下，杰斐逊真的没有什么可失去的。我的意思是，他推翻君主制并没有什么损失。他反而从中获益。哦，如果他们失败了，他就会失去生命。我的意思是，签署那份文件是对国王的叛国罪，
on to that project and they won only because the French helped them if the French hadn't done that. He could have been hanged. So he had something to lose there but I see what you're saying. I think that that's true in the sense that he didn't have as much to gain from fighting slavery. He had a lot to lose, however, because I think Jefferson was probably the most talented politician of his time. And he forged a party that lasted from his election through Jackson. Jackson considered himself to be a Jeffersonian. Nobody's ever done that. Had that kind of political influence over that long a period of time. And he didn't do that by making bad political calculations.
只有在法国人的帮助下他们才赢得了胜利，如果法国人没有这样做，他可能会被绞死。所以他在那件事上确实有东西可失去，但我明白你的意思。我认为在某种意义上这是真的，因为他在反对奴隶制方面没有那么多可获得的利益。然而，他确实有很多可失去的，因为我认为杰斐逊可能是他那个时代最有才华的政治家。他建立了一个从他当选一直持续到杰克逊时期的政党。杰克逊认为自己是杰斐逊主义者。从来没有人做到过这一点。在那么长的时间里拥有那种政治影响力。他并不是通过错误的政治计算做到这一点的。
And we like to think, oh sure, if you had just tried hard enough, you could have convinced Virginians and Southerners to vote slavery out of existence. I think he looked at that and he knew that that was not going to happen. And I think from the distance of history, we can say this could have happened and that could have happened. But I don't think realistically that could have happened. Slavery was going to end the way it ended. No one has given me a convincing scenario how in the United States people could have just voted slavery out without a real, real fight. Sure, he could have worked for that, but if he'd given his life to that, we would not be sitting
我们喜欢想，哦，当然，如果你足够努力，你本可以说服弗吉尼亚人和南方人投票废除奴隶制。我认为他审视了这一点，并知道这是不可能发生的。我认为从历史的距离来看，我们可以说这本可能发生，那本可能发生。但我认为现实中这不可能发生。奴隶制注定会以它最终结束的方式结束。没有人给我提供过一个令人信服的方案，说明在美国，人们怎么能不经过一场真正的、真正的斗争就投票废除奴隶制。当然，他本可以为此努力，但如果他把一生都奉献给这件事，我们就不会坐在这里
here talking about him. I don't believe. I think if he'd come back from France and said, you know, I'm gonna work to end slavery. I don't think he would have been vice president. I don't think he would have been president. So I think for him politically, that was the choice to make, to do the things that he could realistically have a success with. And the things that he quite frankly cared more about than ending slavery. And he was not, I don't believe in the right moment to do that. There are people who argue that judging historical figures
谈论他了。我不相信。我认为如果他从法国回来后说，你知道，我要致力于结束奴隶制。我不认为他会成为副总统。我不认为他会成为总统。所以我认为对他来说，在政治上，那是必须做出的选择，去做那些他能现实地取得成功的事情。而这些事情，坦率地说，他比结束奴隶制更关心。而且我不认为那是做这件事的正确时机。有些人认为，用现代价值观和道德的视角去评判历史人物，
to the lens of modern values and morals, that it just doesn't work. That in some ways our modern notions about racism simply cannot be overlaid onto people living in the 18th and 19th century. In fact, President Trump weighed in on this, in the context of a 19th century. In fact, President Trump weighed in on this, in the context of controversy over Confederate statues. Take a listen.
是行不通的。在某种程度上，我们关于种族的现代观念根本不能强加给生活在18和19世纪的人们。事实上，特朗普总统在关于邦联雕像的争议背景下谈到了这一点。听听看。
This week it's Robert E. Lee. I noticed that Stonewall Jackson's coming down. I wonder, is it George Washington next week and is that Thomas Jefferson the week after? What do you make of this, Annette? I hear what you're saying in terms of the difficulty of superimposing our current values on the past. But at the same time, that hear what you're saying in terms of the difficulty of superimposing our current values on the past.
这周是罗伯特·E·李。我注意到石墙杰克逊的雕像也要被拆除了。我想知道，下周会是乔治·华盛顿吗？再下周会是托马斯·杰斐逊吗？安妮特，你怎么看？我听到了你关于将我们当前的价值观强加于过去是多么困难的说法。但与此同时，
But at the same time, that's what we have. We have our current values. And if we don't superimpose them on the past, then the past continues to live amongst us. Well, you know, I don't adhere to the idea that you don't make moral judgments. I think history is a moral profession. We don't just look back and say, oh, and here's how they slaughter the innocence and go move on. I mean, we do, of course, bring our lens to all of this.
那正是我们所拥有的。我们有我们当前的价值观。如果我们不把它们强加于过去，那么过去就会继续在我们中间存在。嗯，你知道，我不赞同那种不进行道德评判的观点。我认为历史是一门道德职业。我们不仅仅是回顾过去说，哦，这就是他们屠杀无辜者的方式，然后继续前进。我的意思是，我们当然会用我们的视角来看待这一切。
And we also have to think, to remember that there were people at the time, who had some of the same values that we do. So I don't think it's enough to just say, we can't judge people in the past because I, judge may be too strong a word. You can certainly comment on, you can certainly point out the contradictions, you can point
我们也必须思考，要记住当时确实有人拥有与我们相同的一些价值观。所以我认为仅仅说我们不能评判过去的人是不够的，因为“评判”这个词可能太强烈了。你当然可以评论，你当然可以指出矛盾之处，你可以指出
out the differences, the vast, you know, distance between what people in the past thought and what we think. As for, you know, Washington and Jefferson and Monuments, I've talked about this before, I would draw a clear line between the Confederates and the Confederacy and members of the founding generation. I think there's every difference between people who help to create the United States versus people who try to destroy the United States. I don't think that just because they're both in the past,
差异，指出过去人们的想法与我们想法之间巨大的距离。至于华盛顿、杰斐逊和纪念碑，我以前谈过这个问题，我会把邦联及其成员与建国一代的成员划清界限。我认为帮助创建美国的人与试图摧毁美国的人之间有着本质的区别。我不认为仅仅因为他们都属于过去，
that we have to think of them as the same, because they're not the same. They don't bear the same relation to us. I mean, Jefferson has ideals. Not all of Jefferson's ideals do we adhere to, but Jefferson through the declaration and other of his writings, other of his actions, created a set of ideals that we still adhere to, that still have meaning for us. I don't know what the Confederacy means to us. So I draw a distinction between those people, the people,
我们就必须把他们看作是一样的，因为他们并不一样。他们与我们的关系不同。我的意思是，杰斐逊有理想。我们并不认同杰斐逊的所有理想，但杰斐逊通过《独立宣言》和其他著作，以及他的其他行动，创造了一套我们至今仍坚持的、对我们仍有意义的理想。我不知道邦联对我们意味着什么。所以我把那些人，石墙杰克逊那些人，与华盛顿和杰斐逊这样的人区分开来。安妮特，你小时候是第一位融入学校的非裔美国人，在某种程度上，你亲身经历了我们国家在讨论奴隶制遗产方面的斗争。现在，我想知道，在研究托马斯·杰斐逊的一生时，你是否在当今的矛盾中看到了他所经历的矛盾的影子，也许是他忽视或合理化的那些矛盾？它们今天仍然存在于我们中间吗？
Stonewall Jackson and those people, and people like Washington and Jefferson. As a child and at you were the first African-American to integrate your school and in some ways you have personally experienced our nation's struggle to discuss the legacy of slavery. Now, I'm wondering, in studying the life of Thomas Jefferson, do you see echoes in the contradictions that he had in the present day to some of the contradictions that he struggled with, and perhaps ignore or rationalize? Are they still alive with us today?
我想它们非常活跃。关于杰斐逊最迷人的地方在于，在某种程度上他体现了这个国家。我的意思是，他内心的挣扎，当你去蒙蒂塞洛时，你会看到美国最好和最坏的一面。它们体现在这个理想主义者身上，但在某些方面他并没有做到这一点。当然，公民身份，非裔美国人的第一等公民身份，还没有实现。
I think they're very much alive. The fascinating thing about Jefferson is that in some ways he embodies the country. I mean, the struggles that were within him, and that's when you go to Monticello, you get to see the best in the worst of America. And they're embodied in this person who was idealistic, but in some areas did not live up to that. And certainly, the idea of citizenship, first class citizenship for African American people is not, has not come to pass.
我不认为那里还有问题。但我们仍然自诩为一个大熔炉。所以是的，杰斐逊的许多矛盾在我们身上依然存在。我不认为建国一代中有任何人能如此好地体现这一点或展示这一点。这就是为什么他是一个我们无法真正抛弃、无法推到一边的课题，因为他是我们作为美国人是谁的一面镜子。我想知道你是否曾经思考过杰斐逊的生活和他所体现的矛盾，并思考你自己的生活，也许我每周都要坐飞机往返于纽约市和剑桥之间，
I don't believe there are still issues there. But yet we hold ourselves out as a melting pot. So yes, a lot of Jefferson's contradictions are alive in us. I don't think there's anybody in the founding generation who embodies that so well or shows this so well. And that's what makes him a subject that we can't really I think do it out and we can't push to the side because it's too much of a window into us to who we are as Americans. I'm wondering do you ever think about Jefferson's life and the contradictions he embodies and think about your own life and perhaps get on my plane every week to fly
我在做什么来阻止人口贩运，性贩运，我知道这是一个问题。我是一名律师。为什么我没有为此做更多的事情？有很多事情。现在没有什么能达到杰斐逊那种宏大的规模，正如你之前提到的，但我并没有生活在他那种规模中。
back and forth between New York City and Cambridge, what am I doing to stop trafficking in people, sex trafficking in people that I know is something that's a problem. I'm a lawyer. Why am I doing more about that? There are just lots of things. Now nothing is on the grand scale of Jefferson, as you mentioned before, but I'm not living on the scale. He was living.
我不是总统。我没有那种权力。但是的，是的。我认为我们每个人内心都有一些我们知道是错误的事情。由于我们其他的忙碌，我们说，好吧，那件事会自己解决的。别人会想出办法的。那是别人需要处理的事情。
I'm not the president. I'm not in a bad... I don't have that kind of power. But yeah, yeah. I think in all of us, there are things that we know are wrong. And because of our other preoccupations, we say, well, that thing will take care of itself. Somebody else will figure that out. That's for someone else to deal with.
即使我们知道……不，我们本可以做出贡献。所以是的，审视他也会让你审视自己。审视他也会让你审视自己。安妮特·戈登-里德是哈佛大学的历史学教授和法学教授。我们今天一直在谈论她与彼得·奥努夫合著的书《最受祝福的族长：托马斯·杰斐逊与想象力的帝国》。感谢你今天参加我们的“隐藏的大脑”节目。哦，谢谢你的邀请。
Even though we know that it... No, we couldn't make a contribution. So yeah, looking at him makes you think about yourself as well. looking at him makes you think about yourself as well. And I'd go and read is a historian and law professor at Harvard University. We've been talking today about her book co-authored with Peter O'Nuff, most blessed of the patriarchs, Thomas Jefferson, and the Empire of the Imagination. And thank you for joining us today on Hidden Brain. Oh, thank you for asking me.
本周的节目由塔拉·博伊尔、帕斯·沙和基梅拉·瓦尔加斯·雷斯特雷波制作和编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、雷娜·科恩、托马斯·刘、劳拉·夸雷尔和凯特·舒克内希特。今天的节目包括肖恩·凯西饰演托马斯·杰斐逊，迪迪埃·达文克饰演拉法耶特侯爵，杰森·富勒饰演以色列-乔莱特·杰斐逊的表演。特别感谢拉蒂西亚·布洛克和布莱恩·邓恩。我们今天的英雄是我们的NPR同事海德·扎曼、迪特里亚·海兹、阿迪兹·穆恩、苏拉杰·帕特尔，
This week's show was produced and edited by Tara Boyle, Parth Shah and Kimela Vargas Restrepo. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarell, and Kat Shuknecht. Today's show included performances by Sean Casey as Thomas Jefferson, Didier Davenque as the Marquis de Lafayette and Jason Fuller as Israel-Jolette Jefferson. Special thanks to Latissia Brock and Brian Dunn. Our rants and heroes today are our NPR colleagues Heider Zaman, Dietria Heiz, Adiz Mune, Suraj Patel,
和卡尔文·诺。他们最近几周为“隐藏的大脑”团队提供了必要的IT支持。没有他们的辛勤工作和技能，我们真的无法制作出这档节目。谢谢海德、迪特里亚、阿迪兹、苏拉杰和卡尔文。最后一件事，我们正在制作一期关于知识的力量与危险的节目。人们常说，在处理偏见时，最好了解世界是如何运作的。如果你是有色人种，了解种族主义是如何运作的有助于防范它。
and Calvin No. They have helped a hidden brain team with essential IT support in recent weeks. We literally could not have put out the show without their hard work and skill. Thank you Heider, Dietria, Adice, Suraj and Calvin. One last thing, we are working on an episode about the power and perils of knowledge. It's often said that when it comes to dealing with prejudice, it's best to know how the world works. If you are a person of color, it helps to know how racism works to be on guard for it.
知识可以保护你。但有时无知也可能有所帮助。如果你知道人们对你评价很低，这可能是一种阻碍。不知道可能对你有帮助。如果你有一个愿意与“隐藏的大脑”听众分享的个人故事，揭示了这一等式的两面，
Knowledge can protect you. But there are times when ignorance might be helpful too. If you knew people thought poorly of you, this can be an impediment. Not knowing might help you. If you have a personal story you're willing to share with Hidden Brain's audience, that reveals both sides of this equation,
知识的力量，知识的危险，我们很乐意听听你的故事。我们特别对与种族或性别相关的问题感兴趣，但我们也乐于听到其他话题。请找一个安静的地方，在手机上录一段语音备忘录，两三分钟就足够了，告诉我们你的故事。
the power of knowledge, the perils of knowledge, we'd love to hear about it from you. We're particularly interested in questions related to race or gender, but we'll be happy to hear about other topics too. Please find a quiet spot and record a voice memo on your phone two or three minutes is plenty and tell us your story.
如果需要更多信息，我们会跟进。请将您的语音备忘录通过电子邮件发送至HiddenBrain@NPR.org，并使用主题行“Knowledge”。再次提醒，请在安静的地方录制语音备忘录，并使用主题行“knowledge”将其通过电子邮件发送给我们HiddenBrain@NPR.org。请附上电话号码。非常感谢。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
We'll follow up if we need more. Email your voice memo to HiddenBrain at NPR.org and use the subject line Knowledge. Again, record a voice memo in a quiet spot and email it to us at Hidden Brain at NPR.org using the subject line knowledge. Please include a phone number. Thanks so much. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。